okay is it too late to order everything
just order one of everything
[Music]
Oh God okay Wow I've never seen those
giant Starbucks bags all right No Oh
Mike it's mostly drinks I don't see any
food oh there we go there's a food no
it's more drinks well I can't even if we
could drink all of this we would
probably get a heart attack and this
looks like something I would drink this
looks like something I would do ingress
Cheers
Chad what is it like I'm pre-gaming okay
[Music]
let's try the next one my headache
finished another box you guys we're
almost halfway done halfway well I think
we got more actually we have more food
that's good
or is it beef I've never seen these on
the menu oh this is good
and they got onions
[Music]
we drink like like like I'm sure like
I'm positive for drinking of all of this
we only have sweet flush for food now I
think I have better tolerance for sweets
and you it's not because I'm full it's
because like I'm just really shaking
right now
so get higher how do you feel like I'm
happy the sawfish I don't like I don't
like it I don't like the flat sausages
mm-hmm this is hard this is the harder
than I thought
I'm sweating the trees are all starting
to taste like cinnamon hi I was there
we're down to our last stray last drink
a lot of caffeine a lot of sugar I'm
just really make sure their hands very
oh my goodness he could be a scarf well
well it's time to share I don't even
know what they are
[Music]
I'm gonna drop off this beard to say
thank you to the employees at Starbucks
who need all those drinks for us
[Music]
do like a little pick-me-up